you
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
someone's sick there tending pot what in
what someone who stayed out of the
spotlight for a very long time Duke
Nukem now Duke Nukem used to be the top
of his game literally his shoot-'em-up
game was one of the best known in all
the world
so naturally I asked him I said mr. n
where have you been all these years he
says Oh
working on this new game called Duke
Nukem Forever I'll said oh yeah I I
wonder the hearing about that or
supposed to be like this big
groundbreaking game but never got off
the ground and he told me it said well
it went from game designer to game
designer people to people all over
everyone just kept waiting to improve
the technology and nobody could keep up
with the times I said well that's sad
what did you do about it
I says I took over I said you took over
I said yes I took over as the supreme
game designer I handled the story the
characters the gameplay everything about
it Dawson sounds fantastic I mean what
went wrong he said but just another
vision that I had I was a really local
would your vision and they said well it
was gonna be a brand-new kind of
technology or kind technology where you
actually use actors in the game also
Aspen done before it's like no no no not
just laser scan and not just filming
them actual actors from every angle you
can play the actors that's the catch
everything is real I'll sit well that
sounds impressive who are you gonna get
to be in it they says well yours truly
of course
you can without Duke Nukem but then I
was thinking along the lines of Angelina
Jolie and chole Depp
isn't that the highest-paid actress the
highest-paid actor in all of Hollywood
they said Elia I don't dick around when
I'll get the best I'll get the best nos
it but wasn't that expensive I'll attend
that cost you a fortune Isabel sure sure
but money was no object we just want the
best
I said well look at you Oh what were
they doing well Johnny Depp was a slug
monster who distracted his enemies by
shooting out diamonds and our fake
diamonds real diamonds like I said
everything is real everything I said
well what about Angelina Jolie and he
said well she becomes an entrepreneur
and takes over Disney World and again we
really take it over we fork out all the
money and we take over Disney World and
she turns into a bunch of blood sucking
zombies you know more than they are now
so that way I have to go through Disney
World destroy all the famous cartoon
characters and I said well public smells
Duke Nukem I mean the copyright owner
must be a fortune I says that it was but
it's all real it's all real
and asked him finally that that sounds
unbelievably expensive I mean didn't the
game producers have a problem with that
they said well yeah at first but they
were with me for the most part but
they got a little iffy when I brought in
the giant monster Eiffel Tower giant
monster Eiffel Tower I said oh yeah and
again it was the real thing we give it
large mechanical arms legs it will
breathe fire out all the cities but it's
okay he said because we will bring in a
giant mechanical Mount Rushmore imagine
all for the Presidents heads with their
teeth trying to bite off the head of the
Eiffel Tower I said the Eiffel Tower has
a head a says yes I'm Jerry Lewis and
I'll said no none of this would be our
computer animated or digitally said no
it'd be all real everything would be
real this will be the groundbreaking
game of all time and I'll said well that
sounds unbelievably expensive like
beyond comprehension aces car now if I
goes even more beyond comprehension if
because we bring back the Titanic with
tits the Titanic we were gonna call it
it'll be unbelievable we actually bring
it up from under the water
give it tint and it goes in and it
destroys everybody KITT tan it for the
win he said I'll say J that sounds
unbelievably unreasonable a says it gets
even more unreasonable I thought Oh God
for you see after the Eiffel Tower Jerry
Lewis Mount Rushmore Titanic attack I
would do the next best thing I will
purchase a nuclear weapon
producers will day Boyd I'll take it I
launched it and I totally wipeout Canada
first video game in the world to
actually destroy a nation it will be
groundbreaking unbelievable and I'll sit
you can't blow up Canada
that's what fayliss lives where else are
we gonna get movie review that so
unbelievably monotone I said his
monotone will go up an octave once he
sees that joy of mushroom cloud oh but
I'll simple that's an okay that's chaos
that's an expensive use of mindless
violence and they said that's Duke Nukem
Forever
so I said well
what went wrong they said they thought
was too expensive oh what a shock
I'll said look mr. Newcomb I I
appreciate your passion and your energy
but this will cost billions of billions
upon billions upon billions upon
billions of dollars
who on the right mind would pay for that
they said the players would
cuz everybody would buy this game
twice so everybody will buy a video game
tonight I said yes this one they would
that's that that sounds crazy is if you
look me in the eye and tell me they went
call those I couldn't do it I couldn't
say that people honestly will not buy a
game with the Eiffel Tower which I lose
his head attacking and Titanic with its
alt Rushmore with Angelina Jolie Jolie
dev and the entire obliteration of
Canada would you not buy it and I asked
him I said you know obviously the
project didn't go forward but can I give
you some advice
people really seem to like character and
story
I mean groundbreaking technology is nice
but overall they just want to have fun
they just want to enjoy what they're
watching not always be blown away they
have some intelligence
you have to treat your audience with
some respect and dignity
so I asked him I said what did you go on
to do next he said I went out to the
movie Avatar
yeah I wrote the story and directed it
with James camera and everything but I
still want to keep a low profile I don't
mind getting all the credit so just
decide I let him be the big popular one
Oh
how's that dude he's a highest-grossing
movie of all time that's enough
technology groundbreaking story ripped
off
characters not existent also no well I'm
a
I'm glad that's working out for you they
send me to now if you excuse me I have
to smoke a kit I won't believe we'll be
rich so I can do that got a bit left but
an asshole I see a lot of strange things
as a bartender you all strange things at
the pixel Palace so I'll see a lot of
strange things as a bartender at the
pixel Palace and that ain't no lie sweat
you